[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans europe
hebdo c'est parti pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne cette semaine
nous recevons pierre moscovici
le commissaire européen signa un ouvrage
s'il est minuit en europe aux éditions
grasset avant de faire un point sur les
questions budgétaires la question de
relance économique nous avons voulu
aussi l'interrogé sur les grands enjeux
les grands défis de l'europe de demain
avant d'en discuter avec lui petit tour
d'horizon avec aurélie la face est du
style de villers
[Musique]
juin 2016 coup de tonnerre
les britanniques choisissent de quitter
l'union européenne un breakbeat comme le
symbole d'une europe en perte de vitesse
et d'unité déjà en 2015 avec la crise
des migrants
l'europe se fissure près d'un million et
demi de réfugiés arrivent par la mer au
cours de l'année les dirigeants de
l'union multiplay sommet sans solution
l'union se divisent italie et grèce sont
en première ligne pour parer à l'afflux
de réfugiés tandis que l'europe de l'est
fait barrage érige des murs et prône le
chacun pour soi
un repli qui alimente les partis
populistes peggy da et l'afd en
allemagne le front national en france le
you keep en grande bretagne ou encore le
parti conservateur de viktor orban en
gris tous multiplie les victoires face à
ces périls
les partis de gouvernement se déchire au
risque de voir les partis xénophobes et
anti européens devenir majoritaire le
constat est dressé
jean claude juncker président de la
commission européenne met en garde et
pose un ultimatum aux états membres
[Applaudissements]
le ton est venu de parler franchement en
europe
l'union européenne ne va pas bien il y a
pas assez d'europe dans cette union
il n'y a pas assez d'union pendant cette
europe les européens
fête à la désunion et au désamour des
citoyens européens
le défi est immense et la réponse des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement un peu
faible malgré plusieurs sommets les
fractures persiste et se creuse
prochaine étape en italie le 25 mars
2010 est à l'occasion du 60e
anniversaire du traité de rome
une nouvelle tentative pour relancer
l'europe
[Musique]
bonjour pierre moscovici un jours merci
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
alors vous signez aux éditions grasset
s'il est minuit en europe et ce livre
démarre par la possibilité que vous
voyez de voir marine le pen arrivé au
pouvoir en 2010 est est ce que vous y
croyez vraiment est ce que c'est ce qui
nous pend au nez à nous français
non je ne crois pas que marine le pen
sera présidente mais je commence par
dire j'ai fait un cauchemar ce serait un
cauchemar c'est un cauchemar pour la
france c'est un cauchemar pour l'europe
c'est pas quelque chose qui est
totalement exclue on a vu qu'on pouvait
avoir maintenant des élections baroque
aux surprenantes et surtout il ya une
montée du populisme du populisme anti
européen qui est une évidence le risque
probable même c'est marine le pen sur le
deuxième tour c'est pas fatal mais la
surprise serait qu'elle n'y soit pas et
si elle faisait 30 % au premier tour 40
% au deuxième ce serait déjà un choc
considérable et ma thèse c'est que face
au populisme anti européen face à ce
déversement de mensonges sur l'europe de
calomnies sur l'europe de contrevérités
il est temps que les européens les pro
européens se réveille se réveille avec
lucidité
tout ne va pas bien en europe mais soit
aussi beaucoup plus à l'offensive
moi je souffre au sens propre du terme
de voir le terrain de l'ordre délaissés
ou laisser aux populistes laisser au
front national
je souffre dans les prix une
responsabilité collective à pierre
moscovici on a aussi un président de la
république qui ne porte pas assez ce
projet européen
on sort d'une primaire de droite on est
dans une primaire de droite ou le sujet
en fait de l'europe a été complètement
laissés de côté est ce que la classe
politique française est largement à la
hauteur en fait de l'enjeu
non mon appel s'ils s'adressent à tout
son effet il s'adresse
au propre et un qui reste profondément
mais qui par timidité par paresse par
complaisance aussi parce qu'ils pensent
parfois qu'il faut aller chercher les
électeurs du front national font comme
si l'europe était un objet qu'il faut
laisser de côté on n'en parle pas assez
et quand on en parle on en parle mal
mais l'expérience vient d'être fait
y compris dans les primaires à droite
que quand vous parlez comme le front
national ou quand vous avez des tests
qui se rapproche trop de celle du front
national c'est lui qui en bénéficient et
donc caché l'europe comme la poussière
sous le tapis
c'est une faute parce qu'au final ça
donne toujours raison à ceux qui l'
attaquent
voilà pour la raison pour laquelle en
effet je m'adresse aux grands partis de
gouvernement je m'adresse à la gauche
je suis socialiste je le demeure mais je
crois que les socialistes soient des
pro-européens beaucoup plus résolu
beaucoup plus conséquent beaucoup plus
engagé je m'adresse au président la
république est un européen
je pense profondément que c'est son adn
et qui n'a pas fait de fautes européenne
mais j'aimerais qu'il soit plus offensif
si les inventaires diront qu'il manque
un petit peu d'allant il y à une
prudence que je connais qui tient aussi
au fait qu'il appartient à un parti
politique qui s'est divisée en 2005
qu'il connaît les sentiments des
français
il n'a encore une fois pas fait de faute
il a été actif sur la grèce il a une
bonne relation avec madame merkel il
s'est gardé ce que ne font pas quelques
autres même à gauche de toute forme
d'agression de petites phrases à l'égard
des institutions européennes il est
respectueux jamais la vision on attend
qu'elle soit plus fort déjà dans quelque
peu plus forte
voilà pour la gauche le centre gauche
mais la même chose vaut pour la droite
moi je voudrais que les grands partis
politiques portent leur vision de
l'europe
je voudrais que 2010 est l'élection
présidentielle soit le vrai référendum
sur l'europe en france alors justement
le premier tour de la primaire de la
droite consacre pour l'instant donc
françois fillon on verra ce que donnera
le second tour diriez vous que cette
primaire a été
à la hauteur de ce qu'on attende sur les
discours sur l'europe
est-ce que déjà que pensez-vous de
françois fillon est
et enfin qu'est ce que vous avez pensé
donc de ces débats autour de la question
européenne
je suis pas de commentaire à faire sur
françois fillon ou sur l'un juppé il ya
un deuxième tour en raison de potentiels
vainqueurs même si un parent évidemment
meilleure posture que l'autre il faut
laisser le vote se déroule et ça c'est
le respect de la démocratie sont deux
personnalités qui sont des personnalités
de qualité tous deux on était premier
ministre
ils ont sens de l'état et le connaissent
bien sûr par expérience que ce sont des
affaires européennes en même temps moi
je la seule chose que je peux dire c'est
ce que j'en attends est ce que je
constate que je constate c'est que là
l'europe a été la grande absente de ce
débat des primaires de la droite de
manière assez logique au fond parce
qu'on s'est concentré sur d'autres
sujets qui d'ailleurs pouvaient êtres
marginaux et qui n'ont pas fonctionné et
on n'a pas parlé assez des questions
européennes
et puis la deuxième c'est ce que
j'attends ce que j'attends c'est que le
candidat de cette formation
quel qu'il soit françois fillon ou alain
juppé est une attitude pro européenne et
responsable
hélas comme commissaire il ya notamment
une chose que je souhaite vraiment c'est
que la france sache que sa
responsabilité doit être durable dans la
réduction de ses déficits les déficits
sont enfin en dessous de 3 % en 2017
mais ils peuvent aisément rester en
dessous de 3% en 2018 si un peu de
continuité dans la politique et c'est un
objectif
c'est un enjeu de crédibilité politique
et économique majeur pour la france si
on veut demain être capable de relancer
l'europe avec l'allemagne main dans la
main avec l'allemagne d'avoir une zone
euro plus intégrée d'avoir un vrai
budget pour la zone euro d'avoir de
vrais investissements dans la zone euro
devraient créations d'emplois une vraie
lutte contre les inégalités c'est ça que
le message par exemple de l'élection de
trump nous dit si on veut tout ça on a
besoin d'avoir une france solide une
france solide donc c'est un déficit
budgétaire qui est contenu quand vous
entendez justement françois fillon qui
évoque la possibilité de tabler sur 4,7
pour cent de déficit en 2017
c'est irresponsable la seule chose que
je peux dire
c'est que si on regarde l'évolution des
chiffres encore une fois je me base sur
les chiffres
ces 2 9% en 2010 cet essai 3,1 pour cent
la politique inchangée donc sans effort
d'économies supplémentaires en 2018 et
donc il faudra pas faire le coup de
l'héritage ou du legs
on peut décider d'aller à 4 7% mais si
on décide d'elle avec 7 % à se dire
qu'on décide par soi même de faire une
relance budgétaire de l'ordre de 1,6
pour cent et de s'abstraire totalement
du règles du pacte de stabilité et de
croissance
évidemment ça crée en europe quelques
turbulences probablement j'ajoute que un
pic est trop endetté c'est un pays qui
fait des transferts inégalitaire que la
dette elle est payé par les impôts de
ceux qui ont peu à l'égard de ceux
envers lesquels on a emprunté qui sont
souvent les plus riches voilà la raison
pour laquelle quand je dis besson et
déficit je pense est un impératif de
service public
on peut faire le choix inverse je pense
que ce choix est problématique
mais vous comprendrez que l'on va pas
faire rêver nos concitoyens en leur
disant qu'il faut juste baisser les
déficits
j'ai pas mon intention non mais
justement donc j'aimerais bien savoir ce
que quel est votre projet pour relancer
cette europe comment est-ce qu'on peut
réenchanter un petit peu ça le sérieux
est une condition le sérieux n'est pas
un projet en soi et je ne suis
absolument pas un partisan de
l'austérité
je pense au contraire et je les montre
et qu'il faut une appréciation des
politiques budgétaires qui soit beaucoup
plus souple beaucoup plus flexible qui
tiennent compte des inégalités qui
tiennent compte de la situation de
départ des pays
on m'a plutôt reprocher pour le dire le
vrai d'avoir été plus laxistes que
sévère donc non l'austérité n'est pas
mon projet après je vois trois
dimensions pour la relance de l'europe
pour le sursaut européen que j'appelle
de mes voeux une europe qui protège
davantage de une europe qui sur le plan
démocratique soient plus transparentes
qui soient plus exemplaire qui soit plus
un dialogue sur capable de communiquer
mieux est de parler plus simplement
parce qu'elle fait je prends un exemple
je suis en train de préparer une liste
noire de paradis fiscaux pour qu'on
puisse dénoncer certaines pratiques
pour qu'on puisse les sanctionner quand
arrive le texte de la part des services
des commissions ça s'appelle liste des
territoires et juridictions non
coopératives pourquoi ne pas nommer un
chat un chat et ne pas dire voilà sur la
fiscalité par exemple on a besoin de
l'europe et l'europe des choses enfin le
rapport des choses mais elles
communiquent mal alors y'a pas que ça il
ya aussi des choses qu'elle ne fait pas
et enfin la troisième dimension protéger
démocratiser c'est aussi dynamisé avoir
une sécurité par l'euro c'est bien il
faut aussi que l'euro soit un moteur
d'un instrument de croissance voilà
pourquoi je plaide pour qu'il y ait un
budget de la zone euro pour qui une
capacité d'investissement dans la zone
euro que cet investissement se tourner
vers le capital humain vers l'éducation
vers la formation professionnelle vers
l'innovation vers la recherche et
développement par tout ce qui contribue
à élever le niveau dans la société et je
plaide aussi pour qu'il y ait une
gouvernance comme on dit je pense que le
parlement de la zone euro existe c'est
le parlement européen
simplement les pays européens qui ont en
commun leur os peuvent s'organiser mais
je plaide pour qu'il y ait un ministre
des finances de la zone euro qui soit
responsable devant le parlement européen
là encore je prends un exemple je suis
moi a chargé des négociations avec la
grèce au nom de la commission
je vois comment ça se passe ça se passe
entre quatre murs
parfois la nuit dans des termes assez
codée au sein de l'eurogroupe
précisément il ya une interrogation
qu'est ce qui se passe là comment est ce
que vous vous décidez qu'est ce qui fait
que vous prenez telle ou telle option
sévère ou pas par rapport la grèce on ne
s'en explique j'ai même au parlement
pourquoi parce que celui qui préside
l'eurogroupe avec beaucoup de talent
d'ailleurs ironisé blue est à mende du
conseil
un ministre et que donc il ne va pas
devant le parlement européen il me
paraîtrait logique que le futur ministre
des finances de la zone euro qui à mon
sens devrait être aussi un vice
président de la commission européenne
celui qui me succédera en réalité que
celui ci ou celle là puissent aller
devant les commissions du parlement
européen
la veille les eurogroupe le lendemain d
euros
pour qu'il y ait s'expliquer sur une
politique ça s'appelle la démocratie
tout simplement
si on veut que nos concitoyens s'empare
des débats européens il faut que
l'europe le rendre des comptes tout
simplement qu'elles soient pas lointaine
qu'elle soit pas bureaucratique voilà
les propositions les transparences alors
justement vous vous évoquera ses airs de
démocratie et de transparence vous
évoquez la question de l'austérité on a
voulu aller voir au portugal est un pays
qui se relève un petit à petit je te la
semaine dernière et bien voilà donc vous
allez pouvoir nous en parler on a été à
porto sandra cerqueira donc notre
reporter s'est rendu à porto pour voir
un petit peu comment les portugais se
sortait de cette crise
reportage
[Musique]
non
ici on voit que des touristes regardez
la rue plus de touristes que d'habitants
en plein coeur de novembre ils sont plus
d'un million à être venus découvrir
porto depuis le début de l'année quand
jusqu'aujourd'hui le four tual rapport
qualité prix pour les français c'est
très intéressant
puis aussi commencé à entendre parler
vite qui est indécente a listé puis
m'ont hélas depuis hier et on voit bien
que les choses très intéressant pour les
rues du centre ville sinistrée il y a
quelques années avec la crise sont
aujourd'hui un quartier dynamique
la ville est en pleine métamorphose là
vous voyez c'est un hôtel quatre étoiles
qui a ouvert ses portes récemment
avant c'était une maison abandonnée qui
tombait en ruine
ce gérant d'une agence de tourisme dit
n'avoir jamais vu ça des bâtiments
entiers racheté par des investisseurs du
monde entier transformé en hôtel et
restaurant
[Musique]
le phénomène est tel qu'aujourd'hui dans
le centre de porto on ne peut plus faire
de location de longue durée
il n'y a que des locations saisonnières
qui sont proposés tiff airbnb de fait
les habitants de porto ne peuvent plus
habiter ici
d'autant que depuis trois ans le prix du
mètre carré a triplé
c'est sûr que ce groupe touristique
favorise la reprise de notre économie
sur le papier tout va mieux au portugal
des records de fréquentation touristique
des déficits sous contrôle la croissance
qui repart mais en réalité la des
publics et le chômage reste élevé
la reprise est fragile et elle ne
profite pas à la population à la banque
alimentaire de porto on n'a jamais reçu
autant de demandes 120 associations sont
sur liste d'attenté
c'est bon les amis tout est là merci on
se retrouve dans les jours
malgré la fin du plan daide européen
l'austérité perdure aujourd'hui un
portugais sur cinq vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté avec moins de 400 euros par
mois
une grande partie de pauvreté caché
qu'ils n'entrent pas dans les chiffres
parce que ces personnes qui avaient une
situation stable elles ont honte et
n'ose pas demander de l'aide
yolande à à 29 ans elle a perdu son
emploi il ya trois ans et parce que son
mari gagne un peu plus que le salaire
minimum soit 430 euros
elle ne touche plus rien de l'état deux
fois par mois
cette mère de famille bénéficient d'un
panier alimentaire tels que je fais nous
avons deux enfants et c'est dur de tout
payer avec un seul salaire le loyer
toutes les charges le crédit de la
voiture la situation est devenue
difficile des améliorations tout le
monde dit qu'il y en a
moi je ne vois rien
cette association caritative aids les
habitants du nord de porto ils sont
toujours aussi nombreux à demander de
l'aide
la crise sociale ne fait que s'aggraver
à stein stein profil de nos
bénéficiaires a changé ce sont des
femmes les plus jeunes qui n'ont plus
d'emploi souvent avec des enfants en bas
âge c'est la classe moyenne qui s'est
paupérisée ce qui est frappant aussi
c'est de voir que certaines familles que
nous aidions il ya quelques années et
qui s'en étaient sortis reviennent
aujourd'hui les portugais en ont assez
de continuer à se serrer la ceinture
malgré le départ des créanciers
internationaux résultat l'économie
parallèle se développent et si il y à de
la fraude c'est qu'avec une tva à 23%
la note est souvent salée et les ans
pour ne cesse d'augmenter
l'état pour alléger ses dettes privatise
à tout va et réalise des coupes
budgétaires drastiques
les urgences sont quand même devenu
payant au portugal même les allocations
chômage disparaissent un chômeur qui
arrivent en fin de droits au bout de
deux ans même s'ils recherchent
activement un travail ne touche plus
rien et pourtant il faut être réaliste
l'austérité va continuer même si les
politiques disent le contraire
qu'ils fassent face on demande toujours
plus de sacrifices alors ça peut se
comprendre que certains cherchent à
frauder on dirait que l'argent ne suffit
jamais regardé un deux trois quatre
voire complètement vide d'argent par
dans les projet surdimensionné comme ça
une autoroute déserte reliant porto nord
du portugal pour cet homme décidé à
partir en guerre contre les dépenses de
l'état
cet axe symbolise le gaspillage de
l'argent public
cette construction date de l'époque de
l'ancien premier ministre socrates est
mis en examen pour fraude fiscale
blanchiment d'argent et corruption il y
a deux ans yves hamelin d'araki tinto
pourrait passer trente ou quarante ans à
payer ces contrats ruineux voulu parler
politique alors qu'ils ne servent que
les intérêts de quelques-uns
la troïka est aussi intervenu en 2012
parce que ce type de projet nous a
réunis il faut y mettre un terme pour se
relever mais rien n'a été fait
il en est sûre si rien ne bouge le
portugal n'est pas à l'abri d'une
nouvelle intervention de la troïka
[Musique]
pierre moscovici on voit que petit à
petit le portugal se relève mais la
population attend encore de pouvoir
profiter un petit peu de ceux de ce
retour en fait à la croissance est-ce
qu'on a été trop loin dans l'austérité
pour ce pays ce reportage très
intéressant mais quand même assez mal à
l'aise il même à l'aser d'abord parce
qu'on voit ce dont souffrent nos
sociétés cette précarité de ces
inégalités de toutes ces hommes et
toutes ces femmes qui se sentent laissés
pour compte oublié par la politique et
perdants de la mondialisation et ça
c'est vraiment vraiment la réponse que
nous pouvons apporter doit tenir compte
de ces situations et douadi c'est leur
cible et g on doit protéger protégée
socialement être capable aussi
d'investir pour que ces hommes et ces
femmes trouvent un emploi à trouver un
débouché puisse rester sur place dans ce
pays qui se dépeuple bon ça c'est la
première raison pour laquelle je
m'adresse de la deuxième raison pour
laquelle je suis mal à l'aise c'est
parce qu'il est né cesse d'amal gamme
qui est fait là que je n'accepte pas
entre le fait qu'il y ait eu une
austérité une politique difficile
l'europe et la situation économique du
portugal car il faut quand même remettre
les choses à l'endroit
s'il ya eu des politiques difficiles
désendettement c'est parce qu'il ya vu
auparavant des politiques exubérante qui
crée une économie de casino reposant sur
un secteur le btp qui s'est effondré et
on ne fait pas de politique difficile
pour le plaisir on n'est pas masochiste
les précédents gouvernements du portugal
n'ont pas été celui ci ne l'est pas non
plus et donc on aurait l'impression à
écouter les comics va donc il ne
faudrait jamais de réforme
il faudrait des indemnités chômage qui
dure pour l'indemnité pour l'éternité il
faudrait un hôpital où on ne paye jamais
rien non c'est pas comme ça que les
choses fonctionnent dans nos sociétés
les réformes sont nécessaires parce que
il faut aussi des économies qu'ils
soient vraies et des services publics
d'urgence deviennent payantes
c'est parce que je dis je dis seulement
que c'est ce que c'était économistes ni
d'en partager l'esprit est l'espèce
comme ça d' amalgame de tout où il
faudrait ne paient rien et touchent et
pour l'éternité
ce n'est pas possible ce n'est pas
possible enfin dernière chose je pense
que cette sous-estiment ce qui est en
train se passe au portugal
et heureusement c'est à dire une reprise
qui est vraiment là l'ami du temps elle
est encore trop inégalement partagés
elle n'est pas encore complètement
diriger vers ceux qui sont justement les
victimes de ces inégalités mais
heureusement le portugal est en train de
retrouver la croissance et la commission
n'est pas du tout en train de lui
infliger une cure d'austérité c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi je sais content
qu'on ait pu prendre des décisions pour
le portugal qui évite de suspendre les
fonds structurels salavat la capacité il
a été question était question qui aurait
été une sanction en fait un des fessiers
nous ne demandons pas de mesures
supplémentaires
ainsi pour l'espagne d'austérité au
portugal c'est le cas pour l'espagne
cette commission est une commission qui
veut à la fois on respecte les règles
les règles budgétaires parce que c'est
notre obligation juridique mais qui a
une volonté politique et la volonté
politique c'est que la brique budgétaire
soit mise au sein de la croissance c'est
aussi la raison pour l'accès c'est aussi
la raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui
l'europe est autant décrié c'est que on
a aussi ce sentiment beaucoup de nos
concitoyens ont ce sentiment qu'on a été
sauvé les banques lors des dernières
crises qu'ont pu traverser quelques pays
mais que ceux qui payent aujourd'hui
encore les pots cassés ce sont les
européens qui violent du vrai là dedans
mais il ya aussi quand même une espèce
d'immense idée fausse
c'est bien confortable de tirer sur le
pianiste bruxellois pour des réformes
qu'on a envie besoin de faire chez soi
et qu'on ne veut pas assumer
politiquement
est ce à dire que la plupart des genres
dans un double discours c'est à dire
totalement totalement ce discours si la
faute à bruxelles alors qu'en fait on
fait des réformes pour soi même c'est
tellement fréquent et prenez l'exemple
de l'endettement on dit toujours c'est
bruxelles qui impose l'austérité mais
son dtc mourir c'est aussi simple que ça
et puis est ce que je constate tout de
même c'est qu'on a aussi tendance
parfois
mettre sur le compte de bruxelles des
décisions qu'on prend soin même pas ce
qu'est une chose que nos concitoyens ne
connaissent pas ils ont l'impression
parfois que la commission jument de la
commission c'est le gouvernement de
l'europe
nous avons beaucoup de pouvoir c'est
vrai et être commissaire européen est
une responsabilité certaine mais nous
n'avons pas tous les pouvoirs
nous sommes une instance qui propose une
instance qui exécute ses mots qu'ils ont
les propositions législatives ou
financière c'est nous qui administrons
au final le budget et les
réglementations mais ce sont toujours
les états qui décident toujours il n'ya
pas une décision en europe qui ne soient
pas prises par les états membres donc si
on est toujours en train de tirer sur le
pianiste bruxellois comme si l'europe
était une contrainte ou une punition et
jamais un espoir
alors on va tuer l'europe et qui veut
tuer son chien on dit qu'il a la rage
quand vous voyez effectivement vous vous
l'évoquez l'instant l'élection de donald
trump aux états unis nous on a eu le
break site en juin dernier c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui à une forme de souplesse
qui se met en place au niveau européen
pour ne pas avoir à revivre ailleurs en
france en allemagne peut-être ce genre
de situation moi je suis persuadé que
maintenant l'europe doit changer sinon
elle va disparaître changer ça veut dire
être effectivement plus l écoute des
préoccupations de ces peuples davantage
soucieuse des inégalités qu'elle a été
plus transparente qu'elle ne l'a été
plus protectrice était et plus
volontaire sur le plan économique il
faut vraiment maintenant que nous
opérions un tournant pas une rupture
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont déjà en train de se faire la
commission c'est elle qui propose une
politique juste sur les réfugiés c'est
elle qui luttent efficacement c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'a laissé les états qui
n'en veulent pas et oui et oui c'est ce
que je disais sur qui veut noyer son
chien on dit qu'il a la rage
il faut pas tirer sur penny bruxelles où
il faut être il faut faire pâques au
bout d'un moment de s'unir et il est
temps aussi d'aller vers gâtine beaucoup
plus ambitieux sur ventre alors on va
reparler de la grèce barack obama y est
et encore quelques jours est-ce que vous
êtes favorable à une réduction de la
dette grecque
je pense en effet qu'il se passe quelque
chose en grâce c'est donc d'abord la
croissance convient en grèce elle
pourrait être de 3% à peu près en 2017
et 2018
ce qui est aussi une perspective je
crois positive pour le peuple grec qui a
tellement souffert et qui a perdu près
de 27 % de son pib et qu'un taux de
chômage qui est insupportable notamment
de la jeunesse c'est pas possible
et la deuxième chose c'est que le
gouvernement grec fait des réformes
sap a été spontanée ça n'a pas été
évident mais ils prennent leur
responsabilité ils jouent le jeu et ma
thèse mon attitude c'est de considérer
que s'ils prennent leurs responsabilités
s'ils jouent le jeu
nous devons prendre nos responsabilités
noé qui sait les partenaires de la grèce
au sein de leur groupe les autres pays
membres de la zone euro
c'est le fonds monétaire international
c'est la banque centrale européenne
c'est la commission et oui je pense
qu'il faut qu'on envisage une
restructuration de la dette grecque
dans le cas d'un projet global ou une
approche globale où il y aurait le
programme qui se déroule les réformes
qui se font la confiance des
investisseurs qui revient la croissance
qui redémarre l'emploi qui repart et
dans ce contexte là oui je plaide pour
un accord global sur la grèce d'ici à la
fin d'année et vous pensez pouvoir
obtenir une majorité sur cette réduction
de la dette
faut pas une majorité il faut
l'unanimité et il est très important
pour moi que le fonds monétaire
international qui est un partenaire de
confiance un tiers de confiance depuis
le début de la crise grecque soit là
soit présent et donc il faut arriver
marié des thèses qui peuvent être assez
contradictoires par exemple entre la
république fédérale d'allemagne on me
dit non nous ne voulons pas payer plus
et le fonds monétaire international qui
lui est favorable à ce qu'on appelle un
haircut un allègement nominale de la
dette
tout en étant favorable des mesures plus
difficile il ya un chemin
il est roi il est compliqué c'est très
technique mais je pense que nous avons
nous la responsabilité de l'ouvrir en
tout cas maintenant d'ici la fin de
cette année dernière question pierre
moscovici angela merkel a annoncé
qu'elle briguerait un quatrième mandat
de chancelière en allemagne est ce que
c'est une bonne nouvelle cet îlot de
stabilité en europe
on verra ce sont toujours les électeurs
qui décident en démocratie et il va être
une longue campagne
elle s'est déclarée très longtemps avoir
eu comme quoi parfois c'est pas mal de
le faire et c'est une femme qui en tout
cas tout à fait estimable
moi j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour elle
pour le courage dont il a fait preuve
dans la crise des réfugiés
elle a pris des risques l'épais ya pu y
avoir des erreurs mais s'est comporté
laon véritable humaniste j'ai de
l'estimé aussi pour justement la façon
dont elle a répliqué avec les valeurs
européennes à l'élection de donald trump
je pense pour le reste que sur le plan
économique et social en allemagne aussi
qui les inflexions à donner je plaide
par exemple et notamment pour que
l'allemagne soit capable d'investir plus
alors qu'elle a des marges de manoeuvre
budgétaires phénoménal que n'ont pas les
autres et pour elle même et pour le
compte de la zone euro et si j'étais
allemand je suis social démocrate en
france je serai pas aussi social
démocrate en allemagne mais c'est une
femme qu'il faut respecter et qui
apporte beaucoup à l'europe nous verrons
ensuite ce qui se passera lors des
élections allemandes c'est bien sûr les
allemands qui vont choisir c'est pas moi
c'est pas vous c'est pas les français
qui votent
je trouve aussi que taper sur merkel
critiquée merkel non c'est pas quelque
chose qui est
juste une femme qui mérite notre estime
notre respect après dans le champ
démocratique on peut se combattre avec
des steam et respect merci beaucoup
pierre moscovici d'avoir répondu à nos
questions nous c'est la fin de cette
émission mais vous pouvez la revoir en
replay sur nos sites lcp point fr et
publicsenat.fr la semaine prochaine vous
retrouvez ahmed tazir depuis bruxelles
très belle semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]